wie viel so battlebef landet die briefk
sieht die ein sag sie liedet unter spand
sie nicht W andere sagt das nicht anders
wie mir redet
[Musik]
drüber ja heute got zums span wie awen
der Flut V battelbef über das ren wir
später mal got wahnsinnig gut eigentlich
sverständlichkeit dass man ab oder ja
ich find schon Frage wie viel und so das
Red no fin ich schwierig also Stichwort
spandig es geht natürlich abero sag ich
zah stür stüre und das ist Form von
Beteiligung
am ja Sozialstaat am gemeinwesser und
das ist nicht unerheblich und insofern
das ist Teil entwicklammenarbeit und
soer also wieso soll ich n über das SP
also ich find das eigentlich ja schon
nicht ganz vom tich zwischen so schnell
interessant oder wenn man der
Weltreligionen z.B im Al Testament git
sogenannte Z geht aber andere Religionen
und in der Zeit wenn man sich das wenn
die Schriften entstanden sind h
natürlich noch kein Sozialstaat geh das
heißt die Abgabe h zu di geminwen
überhaupt könen instand
zalte natürlich ein Punkt gichitig muss
man sagen
Armut klar undürlich sehr
viel Gefühl also wenn ABG tut nicht so
schnell weh oder und darum stiegt
wahrscheinlich auch Pficht bis und
H ja über das was man da ir stü zahlt
würde ich schon sagen ja sind über 700
Millionen Menschen wo wirklich Hunger an
Hunger undumstin sterbet in der Schwiz
sind ungefähr J die F Person ist v Armut
betroffen je nach
altersstufeer
natürlich Tag
sondern natürlich irgendwie Kind wo
nicht K Skilager g oder wo es schwierig
ist dass S Z freib W W und so wier von
dem her find ich schon es gibt klar
wiesepficht es geht all moralthorie die
vorstellig dass man Menschen in Not
eigentlich h s das ist absolut klar es
Gebot die ein macht das vermutlich aus
Pflichtgefühl in der Schwiz spendet vier
V F Personen regelmäßig also mega viel
fin
auch%m die andere würde das vielleicht
auch machen so warm GL man fühlt sich ja
irgendwie gut also die meist sag W die
regelmäßig Spann tut irgendwi gut klar
ja wir sind alles moralische W und
soziale W und mit la da im West vi mit
lat schuldbewusst und schlechte gewüse
ich find zurecht das ist ja nicht so
dass man einfach jetzt Spann sonondern
wir sind einige von de Schicksal
mitchuld oder die globale Welt ist das
natürlich auch wo Teil DAV sind swort
Kolonialismus und abütig und so weiter
es geht ja aber auch Situation D man
gerade zu genötigt wird Spende nlich so
Personen wo die straßenstell ganz viele
wach die sogenannte
dialoger und fr minut du bist so ein G
das hat mich irgendwie l schockiert
ehrlich gesagt
wieso
n nervig od nicht mus bringen zus und s
getriebenamit me die
me ja ja ich meine das also das ist
jetzt schon 12 Jahre her W ich das
gemachte aber es ist interessante erfahr
das das zu machen und let natürlich sehr
vieles auch so FL frem l diepreche und
so
strategisch ja du g
und stell immer frageo nicht sag das ist
Trick oder wenn du ja sag ist chsgebot
und bist offen oder ja aber ich sag
einfach n Gang einfach
jachf nein ich hab das für Organisation
gemacht wo irgendwie kein Erfolgsdruck
und sehr sehr sinnvoll und
ich wie effizient die die Organisation
ist und ja mir hätte es e Spaß gemacht
und nicht irgendwie sind abütet W ke
Konkurrenzdruck gab sondern es ist eher
du Versuch sie l zu dem bringen was mir
selber gut gefunden weiß wie viel das
weiß wie viel al l nachher irgendwche
Last Verfahren unterschrieet und das
Geld ab nein Entschuldigung nein ich
finde das ist sehr von der Urteilskraft
und vom fingerspitzfühl V
menschenkennnis abhängig ich hat jetzt
nie irgendwie dazu braucht glaube ich
und ich finde die H jetzt nicht verstand
was Gott und und ich irgendwie weiß
nicht was da passiert es kann dass das
geht aber ich glaub das H wir nicht
gemacht und interessant ist du
g und
noch
Trick s ich jetzt mal du rück zu und
zeig du laufst davor und niemand h
frheit und ein Weg dieft mit schon
interess ich strah du findest großartig
ich fin Form Zwang ich find gar nicht
ich fin ne ich
finde entscheiden g
grüing g will
machen
ch aber das
istiv Mens so funktioniert sind doch ke
vernunftroboter war in moralisch
Hinsicht gut W das sind nicht besser
machen D auf der men du und das
wichtigge Punkt das Frage was ist
überhaupt grundlag der Pflicht V Spende
und es ist nicht nur dass es andere
Menschen schlecht geht sondern
involviert sind in ungch die Welt yes
also das heißt Pflicht Spende ist
hilfspflicht sondern eigent nicht
schädigungspflicht oder wieder gutmachig
das ist so Theorie wo ausgangen ist von
Thomas poge aberora oil kananerin
übrigens findet sich das Argument schon
nälich wirk die vorstellig Weltarmut die
extreme Armut viel mit ungerech
handelsbezieh dur
kolonialismusesprochen
historis genau oder die ganze
rstofau sehr unf zum wiederum Kasse V
der diktatore füllt das heißt das ist
ganz anders Bild wir sind nicht warm
Glow mäßig wahnsinig wenn spendet
sondern es ist Pflicht will mir
profitiert von der Welt wo andere
Menschen drunter liedet wir sind einig
ein Teil ABG das S Pflicht kann man
begründen mit der hilfspflicht oder mit
der nicht schädigungspflicht aber
vielleicht F komplizierter wird wenn man
die Kritikerinnen und Kritiker sagt das
nützt alles überhaupt
sogar n schlimmer die ganze
entwicklungshilf schadig eigentlich
langfristig die Länder das so eine
Kritik Mo oder von Willam sag das Geld
also so viel Geld sch gespendet
versichert und die Lander in
Abhängigkeit das ist sicher Punkt und
andere ist z kurzfristig wenn irgendwo
Zunami alle fürkt wieder die
Hilfsorganisation gar nicht schaffen die
löhnzahl und soiter darum ist wichtig
konstant Spenden oder dass man irgendwie
Struktur veränder das ist und das zeigt
wieder un Empathie Schock Spende ist ja
nicht so hilf oder sondern irgendwie man
muss es den vernunftmäßig machen so gut
wie es Gott aber das ist jetzt wiederum
anderes Argument das ist quas frag wir
Spende min Punkt wie es geht die wo sag
entwicklungshilf nützt gar nicht egal
wenn du spendest und gerade humanitäre
hilf oder die kurzfristige hilf also
humanitäre Hilfe ist quasi das wenn ein
tunami
Problem nur spkmen wie du sag D den sehr
viel gespandet wird während dem
Entwicklungshilfe ofenig aber die würde
sagentwicklilf ist Schwierigkeit aber
das
andere NZT nicht nur symptomkämpf
das wo jetzt sterb oder du kannst nicht
sag okay ursach bekämpf das korrupte
politische System oder die Regler vom
Welthandel oder so aber jetzt die L
jetzt und L jetzt run oder ich finde du
müsst wie beides machen oder will du
kannst nicht das sagen nur immer wieder
wier mus machen wenn du
nichtören das ist do Argument oder genau
ich B völlig mit dir einig ich glaub
andere Punkt die wo das kritisiert würde
sag nicht machen die würde z sag was man
bra sind FA Reg für Welthandel z.B den
Spende für sogenannte Entwick politische
Organisationen also Vers wo versucht der
welthandl kchter zu machen das heißt du
bist den nicht quasi entl Pflicht
sondern es geht wirklich
andere Fokus und das waso du sag man
natürlich viel gnt das entwicklungshilf
natürlich vieles auch schief gaufen ich
glaub das muss man ganz klar sagen es
sind immer wieder a Skandal aufdeckt
wurde dank man nur damals dr wie
milchbulf verteilt h in
Entwicklungsländer und Abiss h als Form
von entwicklungshilf viel besser W dass
die Frau still also es h viel
Skandal aber es git z. Test duflo die G
Sternstunde
nobelittlerw und sie ist eine von der
ganz bekannte forscherinen auf dem
Gebiet und wandet eiglich das wo man
kennt von der Medikament Studie nlich
die sogenannte randomisierte Studie auf
entwicklungshilf das heißt sie nimmt dr
type von Dörfer z.B geht im ein Dorf
bispelw jetzt es mal
ab so fertig
malar genau im im zweit Dorf malarianetz
plus pund Linse und im drit zum mal plus
irgendwie Untersuch von der schwangere
Frau und dann lt man nach jah wo sind am
meisten malariaanet denn wirk auch und
wo h z. Malaria das sind unsuch gemacht
wer tut das verglich und dann weiß man
wie man eigentlich entwicklungshilf
genauetz also man sch ut
Gefühl instrumentalisiert irgendwie die
L und die W zufällig GEW und nicht zu
der Kontrollgruppe Gehör wirklich Dings
nicht das Medikament die einfach Glück
so aber ich glaube es ist gut zssen was
wirklich funktioniert oder damit man
danach sagen okay das Geld das H
wirklich ein wirk und das ist das große
Problem das VI dem Geld versichert und
anders oder klar was
wirklich ich glaub das beschäftigt ja
viel D man Brief denkt ja wenn ich jetzt
da 100 Franken schicke h das irgende
wirkig oder versichert das irgendwo oder
unterstützt sogar ir das korrupt regim
das ist schon viel Hand also ich glaube
von wichtig dass manärt wel
Organisationen nach wel Standards
versuchen wirklich ih hilfsw irendell
darum geht
oder die
entwicklungshilfsorganisation ein von
der Problem ist dass man immer lieber
kurzfristig spandet wenn gerade irgend
das Drama sich irgendwo ereignet h und
die langfristige hilf BBT dann auf der
Strecke oftmals ist das aber nicht
effektivste wo man könnte machen und das
ist sozusagen Theorie oder die Idee
hinen am sogenannte effektiven
Altruismus
Idee oder bewegig wo im Moment immer
mehr Mitglieder gewünhnt und wo die
Philosophie ih Wurzel hat und über die
wer ich jetzt noch mit dir diskutieren D
zugt das ganze glaub ja im Grund
überzeugt mich das sehr stark muss ich
wirklich sagen ich
find recht radikal aber gut also das
kommt V Peter Singer jetzt australische
Philosoph den jetzt William mcask z.B so
eine Figur Oxford schottische Philosoph
sehr jung Professor und die Idee ist
eigentlich dass du versuchst gut aber
möglich effizient und effektiv also
nicht einfach irg wo du kennst
zufälligerwies und was vielleicht nicht
so dringend Bruch sonder wirklich wirk
und wie kann ich mit dem den Ressource
von Hand Z und Geld beste a der mus hol
also möglich viel mchlabette möglich für
liedensfeiige Wese als Armut ist wichtig
aber ti recht sind für die Denker z.
wichtig also einfach sozusagen das
möglichst
effektiv das ist Grundprinzip oder das L
oder ganz klar
es natürlich find ich ab V der
Humanität einfach unmittelbar wo braucht
hilficht Nachbarschaft viicht braucht
irgendwie Nachbar winterstel und das
nicht zah sonder
mit den 100 Franken kann ich viel besser
im Global Süder Augenoperationen für 20
Kind zah also müsst das machen radikal
dericht ist jedes Menschen gleich viel
wert egal wo die Mensch le und auch egal
wenn die Mensch das also Zukunft die
zukünftige Generation das finde ich das
die radikalform vom Universalismus vom
Kant du so Höch oder jedes menschenle
gich viel wert egal wo die let und das
find bestechend gut das die
unparteilichit Grundidee von Moral
überhaupt me Sicht das L mir schon Stück
wie genau das vorher gemint hab W zu
moralmaschine es gar drum die
Menschlichkeit
sondern ist nur so
effektivitätsprinzip man könte F schon
sagen der Platon h mal die schalt von
der Macht Philosoph Sitz die sag den wo
lang Gott Politik Demokratie das hat
alles gar kein Wert mehr sondern
eigentlich hat die am libwche Technokrat
der schel wo g einfach umverteil doch
ich glaube Stück schon ich find das
serch es muss nicht unpolitisch se du
kannst wier beides machen du kann gich
für die richtige richtige parteie
der Wahl aber du das heißt mit dem
trotzdem kan wenn du spanis das effektiv
spis und es sie sag z.B du sollst auch
Job noch der mus earning to give also du
musst zum ich sit für ke sehr gute
ausbildig qualifiziert ist ist
vielleicht sinnvoller nicht in
entwicklungshilfsorganisation sondern
bkerel ver und aber
omin Effek Alen
kryptolerank freed im Moment eine größte
Skandal verwickelt wo
überhaupt W und
interessant das
genauemach symptomatisch für die ganze
für die ganze bew
im
wirklich drum dass du eigentlich so viel
Verdi möglich und den spand aber h total
apolitische Personen will du eigentlich
du weiß ganz genau das grundlag auf der
du so viel verdienen h ist System wo
letendlich auch nicht hilfich ist zum so
veränder dass es überhaupt weniger Armut
GT ich würde sagen das eine tun das
andere nicht
lassening und spendet nichts von dem
Geld das die rechnet einfach a die
machen rechn du komst am Schluss bessere
Resultat aber du hast doch nicht alles
bere auf der ganze Welt ich sehe das
wirklich nicht es gibt z V Chef besos V
Amazon V dem war sch von dem weiß man
der H Gesetz bekämpft was drum Gang W
soziale Wohnungsbau in siattel
vatriebe stattdess gespendet für für
quasi betre V Obdachlose in das absurd
das ist absurd und was passiertat Chef
das ist daso mich stört sind übrigens
ich das mal no sagen sind fast nur
Männer ja ab was das Lied weiß ich nicht
was einig sind wenn hilft s probieren
mög effektiv hen das sehen auch ich se
auch dass die effektiven altr vi von den
G so ein PL ab so einen Schwur dass Sie
10% lebenslang werd Spende das ist sehr
viel und das bewunder ich wirklich wenn
Menschen sagt lebenslang geb ich 10% ab
das könnte mir machen ich glaube du
machst das nicht ich ma das nicht ich
finde das wirklich scho was machen wir
jetzt mit all den Briefe aicht V der
Philosophie schei klar solange so gut
Gott haben wir sich Pflicht e kümmer um
Dir wo sehr viel weniger gutt für was
spendet ihr wir sind gespannt schri und
wenn dir e e Aufmerksamkeit W schenke
oder spand dann gibt zwei Gespräch mit
der Ester duflo und dem ab Ban und Eis
überstüre